the press waited in vain as negotiators
left Minsk empty-handed talks scheduled
for Friday were called off indefinitely
this as Kiev and pro-russian rebels
exchange 372 war prisoners as agreed on
Wednesday the ongoing crisis continues
to strain relations between Russia and
the West and President Vladimir Putin's
moved to sign a new military doctrine
poses a further problem the document
labels NATO a fundamental threat to
Russian security it echoes Putin's
recent accusations that NATO's buildup
in Eastern Europe coupled with Western
sanctions are meant to [ __ ] Russia
because it's grown too strong last week
he stated a chitinous nobody will
intimidate restrain or isolate Russia
nobody has ever succeeded in this you
got valuable Achilles the doctrine is
also seen as a reaction to Kiev's
decision earlier this week to renounce
its non-aligned status a first step
towards a possible bid for NATO
membership the move has further fueled
tensions Moscow accuses Ukraine of
threatening peace in Europe Kiev for its
part also cited security concerns when
it announced the suspension of all
transportation services to the Crimean
Peninsula which Russia annexed in March
auskey like you Kiev did not say how
long the suspensions would be in effect